[BLEEP] ABOUT THIS!
IF YOU WANT TO MOVE IT, LET'S
GET A MOVE!
>> Sean: JOINING US WITH THE
REACTION, REPUBLICAN
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM IS WITH
US.
WHY WOULD I EVER GET IN THE
MIDST OF A FIGHT LIKE THAT?
INTERESTING SQUABBLE.
BUT YOU CAN SEE -- THINK ABOUT
THIS, SPEAKER PELOSI PULLED
EVERYONE TOGETHER, YOU HAVE
SOMETHING TO SAY TO ME, SAY IT
TO MY FACE, NOT ON TWITTER.
YOU'VE GOT TO GIVE CONGRESSWOMAN
OCASIO-CORTEZ CREDIT.
SHE WENT RIGHT OUT AND SLUGGED
RIGHT BACK.
I'M LIKE, GOOD FOR HER.
A LOT OF COURAGE.
>> WHAT DOES THIS REALLY MEAN?
I THINK REPUBLICANS ARE MORE
LIKELY TO TAKE THE HOUSE BACK
BECAUSE OF THIS BREAKDOWN
BECAUSE THERE ARE 31 DEMOCRATS
WHO HOLD CONGRESSIONAL SEATS
WHERE PRESIDENT TRUMP WON THEIR
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT.
WHAT DOES IT MEAN FOR 31?
IF YOU CROSS AOC, YOU ARE GOING
TO GET A PRIMARY.
IF YOU VOTE WITH THEM, YOU WILL
LOSE IN THE GENERAL ELECTION FOR
THE BIGGEST BENEFICIARY WILL BE
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP BECAUSE THE
POLICIES THESE PEOPLE ARE
PUSHING ARE SO OUT OF THE
MAINSTREAM.
IF YOU ARE ONE OF THESE 31
DEMOCRATS, SEAN, YOU'VE GOT TO
PICK BETWEEN THE ENERGY OF THE
FAB FOUR AND THE PRACTICALITY OF
NANCY PELOSI, YOU ARE IN A
NO-WIN SITUATION.
>> Sean: MAY BE I'VE ONLY IN
POLITICS 30 YEARS IN RADIO, 30
YEARS ON THE FOX, I'VE BEEN HERE
AT THE BEGINNING.
YOU CAN SEE IT IN MY HAIR.
HERE'S WHAT I'M THINKING.
THE MODERN DEMOCRATIC PARTY,
THEY WANT OPEN BORDERS, TAKE
DOWN THE WALLS, LAWS ARE
IMMORAL.
THEY WARRANTS WHEN OBAMA WAS
PRESIDENT.
NOW YOU HAVE NO OTHER CHOICE,
MEDICARE FOR ALL PRAYER THEY
WANT HIGHER TAXES.
THESE 2020 CANDIDATES SUPPORT
THE GREEN NEW DEAL.
EVERYTHING IS FREE.
EVERYTHING.
BY THE WAY, NO OIL, GAS,
LIFEBLOOD OF OUR ECONOMY, NO
COMBUSTION ENGINE, EVENTUALLY NO
COWS AND PLANES.
IF I'M DONALD TRUMP?
I'M A HAPPY GUY TONIGHT.
>> IF I'M PRESIDENT TRUMP, I'D
GO TO FLORIDA AND SHOW UP NEXT
NOVEMBER AND GET REELECTED.
>> Sean: IS THAT ALL IT'S
GOING TO TAKE?
>> LITERALLY, MR. PRESIDENT, IF
YOU ARE WATCHING TONIGHT, ENJOY
THIS, BE QUIET.
HERE'S WHAT THEY ARE SAYING.
THEY ARE GOING TO DECRIMINALIZE
CROSSING THE BORDER ILLEGALLY.
AND ONCE YOU GET HERE, THEY WILL
GIVE YOU FREE HEALTH CARE.
HOW MANY PEOPLE IN THE WORLD DO
YOU THINK WILL TAKE US UP ON THE
OFFER, COME TO AMERICA, NO MORE
CRIMINAL LIABILITY, AND WHEN YOU
GET HERE, WE WILL GIVE YOU FREE
HEALTH CARE.
THIS IS INSANE.
IT'S INSANE!
>> Sean: BUT THEN YOU'VE GOT
THIS WHOLE OTHER SIDE AND
SOMETHING YOU WANTED ME TO ASK
YOU A QUESTION.
THEY ARE OBSESSED WITH A FIFTH
AND SIXTH INVESTIGATION!
THE FBI CONCLUDED, HOUSE INTEL
CONCLUDED, BIPARTISAN SET AN
COMMITTEE, AND THE SPEED AND
REPORT!
NO CONSPIRACY, NO COLLUSION.
NO UNDERLYING CRIME, UNLIKE
KILLARY, SUBPOENAED EMAIL,
BLEACHING, ALL THAT.
YOU'VE GOT THE ABILITY TO BRING
IN ANDREW WEISSMANN WHO WE LEARN
TODAY RESPONSIBLE FOR HIRING ALL
THE CLINTON DONORS, EVEN
CLINTON'S ATTORNEY FOR ROBERT
MUELLER.
YOU ARE GOING TO DO THAT?
>> I'M GOING TO LET BOROWITZ DO
HIS JOB TO TELL US WHAT HAPPENED
WITH THE FISA WARRANT PROCESS.
I'M GOING TO EXPLAIN TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT EVERYBODY
WAS INVESTIGATING TRUMP HATED
HIS GUTS AND LIKE CLINTON.
I'M GOING TO HELP TELL THAT
STORY, BUT I'M NOT GOING TO DO
ANYTHING UNTIL HORWITZ ISSUES
HIS REPORT.
WE WILL TRY TO LAY OUT THE FACTS
OF THE CASE AND IN THE FUTURE IF
YOU APPLY FOR A FISA WARRANT YOU
HAVE TO TELL THE COURT, BY THE
WAY, THE CHIEF INFORMED HERE THE
PERSON THEY ARE LOOKING AT, IT'S
NOT VERIFIED.
SO I WILL DO THAT, HERE'S WHAT I
WANT YOU TO UNDERSTAND.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS
IMPLODING, THE IMMIGRATION
POLICIES ARE NO MORE CRIMINAL
LAW LIABILITY, YOU DO NOT GET FR
LAW LIABILITY, YOU DO NOT GET FE
HEALTH CARE,
THAT'S INSANE.
>> Sean: I'VE BEEN DOWN TO THE